Let's now address this real briefly.
Okay,
this was sent to me. You know how MUI
Luftonia started controversy because
he's saying that Vatican is making a
place for Muslims to pray. Well, if we
look at it in context, let me explain.
Let's read the context. The Catholic
Herald Vatican Library grants Muslim
scholars a prayer room. Did you catch
it? This is for Muslim scholars
who are going to be in the Vatican
library examining manuscripts related to
Islam. So, they're going to be spending
weeks, maybe months, examining the
manuscripts. Because if you don't know
this, the Vatican Library has relics
that go back over a thousand years.
Relics,
manuscripts,
inscriptions that go back over a
thousand years. Some of the oldest
inscriptions, manuscripts are in the
Vatican library.
It is a
treasure trove of ancient artifacts. So,
the Muslim scholars want to go and see
the manuscripts that the Vatican library
has related to Islam.
And since they're going to be pretty
much living there and examining these
manuscripts, they need to pray sadly to
their fake god. So let me put in
perspective.
Muslim scholars visiting the Vatican
Apostolic Library are being accommodated
with prayer spaces. Its vice prefect has
confirmed. Father Jako
Cardonali vice prefect said in an
interview with the Italian newspaper laa
that Muslim academics had requested a
small area in which to pray and the
library had agreed. Some Muslim scholars
have asked us for a room what a carpet
for praying and we have given it to
them. Now I pray every night that they
go and exercise that room pleading the
blood of Jesus Christ over it. The
Vatican library found in the mid 15th
century and often regarded as the
intellectual heart of the Catholic
Church houses a vast array of
manuscripts and texts from across the
world's religions and cultures. Father
Carnelli said its collection include
incredibly old Qurans
alongside Hebrew, Ethiopian, Arabic, and
Chinese works. We are a universal
library. Explain. That's why they're
there.
You understand?
That's why they're there.
They want to examine all these
manuscripts related to Islam. Let me get
you the link
now.
What is my view on that? Here, here's
the link for all of you. I'm going to
let me read it, then I'll give you my
two cents worth. Okay. The vice prefet
also drew attention to some of the more
unusual items in the collection, such as
what is believed to be the oldest
medieval Japanese archive outside Japan.
The archive preserved thanks to a
Cissian missionary, Father Mario,
who lived in Japan during the 1920s.
According to Father Cardelli, the
missionary discovered the documents when
he noticed children playing with a ball
of paper made from old manuscripts.
Realizing their significance, he rescued
them from a ruined castle, thus saving
them decades later from the devastation
of the atomic bomb. It was either a
sensational stroke of luck or
inspiration from above. Father Carnelli
said today the Vatican library is
estimated to contain some 800,000
manuscripts.
Say that
800,000
manuscripts.
Okay, we got it.
And you're telling me the Roman Catholic
Church has not been blessed, that the
church
has not been preserved by God? I I don't
know what to tell you guys. Is your
hatred of the Catholic Church and your
hatred
of the Pope such that you don't
want to acknowledge that God has
preserved this church and all these
artif artifacts till this day and
barring a nuclear bomb destroying most
of the world it's not going anywhere.
I don't know what to tell you guys. Now
you guys get rid of the hate. You can
still believe your church has the
fullness of the truth and still respect
and acknowledge that the bishop of Rome
goes back to the apostles and in spite
of your differences, the Lord is
preserving them,
right? Just like he preserves the Coptic
Christians, the Assyrian Church of the
East, Syriak. I mean, come on. Anyway,
not to belabor the point.
800,000 manuscripts, guys. I'm sorry.
80,000. Holy Spirit, correct my mistake
and error on the spot. That's why I need
glasses. Not 800. Forgive me, Lord.
Thank you. Just again, I don't know why
I saw too many zeros. 80,000
manuscripts.
That too is huge. 80,000 manuscripts,
50,000 archival items, nearly 2 million
printed books. Now, I'd like that number
in my bank account,
but I'll settle for 50,000. No.
What? What? Shoot. What? 50,000, man.
That's how much I owe the IRS. I'll
settle for 500,000. And more than
100,000 engravings, prints, coins, and
metals. New discoveries continue to
emerge, including a rare manuscript of
Spinosza's ethics on Earth in recent
years.
The library's vast digital catalog has
also opened its holdings to the wider
public though it has led to an influx of
eccentric queries. We receive the most
observed requests especially from
America. Father Cardelli said, "Do you
have a time machine
and the manora from the temple in
Jerusalem that Titus took away in the
Holy Grail?"
He also reflected on the growing impact
of artificial intelligence on scholarly
work, suggesting that while technology
may assist in cataloging, it cannot
replace human discernment. Yeah, AI is
going to be the end of civilization
preparing for the return of our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ.
The problem is the same as it was 500
years ago. Cataloging, he said, a
computer may help, but I don't know if a
machine would recognize a forgery. See,
maybe yes, maybe it wouldn't be able to
reconstruct the complicated history. The
Vatican Apostolic Library located within
Vatican City traces its origins to Pope
Nicholas V
and has since served as one of the
world's leading repositories of
Christian and human knowledge. Its
willingness to accommodate visiting
scholars of all faiths. Did you catch
it? not just Muslims
reflects the institution's continuing
role as a center of universal learning
and cultural preservation. Okay. Now,
now that we know the context, let me
chime in.
All right. Now that we know the context,
can I chime in?
Okay. Number one, they're not building a
mosque for Muslims in general. They're
not even building a mosque at all.
That's number one. What they're doing is
allowing a space in the library for the
Muslim scholars that'll be spending time
there examining the ancient manuscripts
related to Islam, like the Quran
manuscripts,
to examine them because they can't take
them until they leave. So, they gave
them a little prayer room with a carpet
to pray on. Okay. Number two, now let's
explain this. If you say they shouldn't
do it, and listen, I hate Islam,
but here is the dilemma for all of us.
Here's the dilemma for you and I. If you
refuse them this right,
and this is Vatican, this is the
Catholic Church, which the world looks
to as being the head of Christianity.
Brethren, when I play the debate between
IP and this guy, what is it? Beck lever,
you will hear him continue to say, "The
Catholic Church is the ancient church.
It's the true church. It came before you
Protestants." You're going to hear him
say that over and over again. What does
that mean?
That means in the eyes of the world
whether you like it or not the pope is
seen as the head of the church and the
Catholics outnumber all other
Christians. Right? There are more
Catholics worldwide than there are
Orthodox and also Protestants. Okay, I
need you to listen to this.
Yes, I'm going to help you right now.
Since the world views the Catholic
Church and the Pope, right, as
Christianity, as the ancient church, as
true Christianity, whatever Vatican
does, whatever comes out of the Vatican
will affect Christians of all branches,
denominations all over the world,
whether you like it or not. Okay, now a
little wisdom. Why is the snakes
harmless as doves? Wise as snakes,
harmless as doves. Little wisdom here.
Okay. Do you remember when Pope Benedict
quoted
a medieval source saying Muhammad
brought nothing good
because everything good was already
there. What he brought was pretty much
destruction and the huge uproar and
outcry by Muslims and that Christians
started getting attacked because of the
Pope's statement. Did you guys remember
that or you forgot?
You guys remember that or you forgot?
Check it out. Pope Benedict was simply
citing what a medieval Christian said
about how evil Islam is. That Muhammad
brought nothing good.
Go ahead on Google to Google it.
Anything good was already there in
Christianity. What he brought was evil.
What he brought was destruction. Evil.
and the outcry and the uproar and the
backlash against Christians.
So he had to come back and qualify
statements cuz he saw blood was on his
hands. Don't believe me? Go to chat GBT
the greatest scholar the world has ever
known because everyone's using it I see
even for debates. Go there and see if
I'm lying. Okay. So what's my point? If
you have the Vatican
refusing to allow the Muslims to pray,
but then you want Muslim countries to
open up the freedom for Christians to
build churches, right, and worship
freely without the fear of violence.
How's that going to work out?
You understand the dilemma? If you say
no, you can't pray here, then they're
going to say, "Well, the hell with all
you Christians. Then you won't be able
to pray in our lands, and we won't let
you renovate churches or build new
ones." You get the point?
How's that going to work out globally,
worldwide? And I'm not trying to pop.
I'm trying to see the logic of it. If
you say no to them, then they're going
to say no to you. And then what this is
going to do is justify
justify
their continued
Christians and the of churches as
they're doing in Nigeria. You
understand?
So the Catholic Church and the Pope are
in a situation, damn if you do, damn if
you don't,
right? Damn if you do, damn if you
don't.
You with me there? Are you understanding
it? So knowing the responsibility as in
the eyes of the world, knowing that his
actions will impact other Christians,
even those who are not Catholic, do you
think they make
do you think they make a distinction
that oh well you're not Catholic?
Knowing that one wrong move can then
cause Christians their lives or cause
Christians to lose their right to gather
in churches. What is he supposed to do?
So, you think it's easy to be the bishop
of Rome where the world sees you as the
head of all Christians. You think it's
easy
knowing that no matter what you say,
what you do, the world is watching you
and they want you to do something so
they can justify what they intend to do
against Christians.
>> Yep. You understand?
Because I am stupid and rash. I would
have told the Muslim scholars, "Go to
hell. You ain't going to pray here."
Because I'm too stupid. I'm not bright.
That's why I'm not a leader because I
would react in emotion. Not
understanding my actions will affect
Christians. So guys, what do you want
him to do? What do you want the Vatican
to do?
What do you want the Vatican to do? Be
realistic.
The world looks to the Catholic Church
as being the epicenter or Vatican
and as being original Christianity.
Very careful.
Very careful. In fact, a rabbi, a Jew,
wrote about Pope who saved Jews from the
slaughter of mustache man. They even
built a forest of trees in Israel to
honor his memory.
Oh yeah. Well, Nina, you're over there
on on Rumble. God bless you, sister.
You're not blocked here. You're one of
my mods here too, right? So, yep. Pope P
the 12th. I have the book written by a
rabbitic Jew praising Pope P the 12 for
doing as much as he can to save Jewish
lives. And you know right now in Israel,
every Gentile that saved the Jewish
life, they plant a tree. In his honor,
they planted a forest of trees for all
the Jewish lives he saved.
You understand? I'm not lying, man.
These are facts, dude.
So, what do you want him to do? I don't
know.
I thank the Lord. I'm not a leader
because my anger, my rashness, I would
do something in anger and then I would
then get Christians persecuted because
I'm stupid. I really am stupid.